like you told me i saw what was that
story i think it was like maybe like the
first time
the first time you went undercover
when i was making a buy yeah yeah so
years ago
i'm talking ages ago um i went to
operations and so they're like hey why
don't you go you know buy drugs and i'm
like alright sounds like a good idea
like i've never done it i'm young i'm
like 22. i'm like all right cool you
know and i'm dressed like this and it's
winter time and you know i'm talking
like back in like 2001 when you know a
bag of clothes and big jackets that's
how we and that's how everyone dressed
so i'm walking around trying to find
somewhere to buy drugs and i meet these
um two guys that are looking to buy
drugs and they're like hey man we're
gonna go over here and buy some drugs
i'm like all right let me call my buddy
let him know he's like look they're
giving out testers which are like free
to try to get you hooked okay oh my god
cool yeah i put them all in a big old
phone i'll call and hey man we're going
over here to get testers you guys should
come just so they know where i would be
yeah i have a radio in my pocket but
again like i said we had big clothes
back then it was turned off and just
slid in my pocket
so we go get in this line and there's
like 150 people in this line up to get
looking for the testers
so i got there a little early so they
put me in this it was in a yard and the
yard was a six foot fence of cinder
blocks so one way and one way out unless
you climbed over the wall there's about
40 of us in the yard and about another
maybe 100 lines up in the alley
you know we're in here waiting i'm
making in my mind like this is awesome
you know what i mean like this is what i
signed up for yeah you're undercover
right so here comes the guy he's got a
freezer bag of heroin i mean this is a
freezer bag yeah it's probably like 6
700 pills in this thing so what what's
your in that situation what you're just
trying to buy it and get the [ __ ] out or
you got are you going to arrest them no
at that point i'm just trying to get the
pill walk out and then tell the guys to
come grab them when i get walk away far
enough you know because it's supposed to
be a tester so it's supposed to be free
yeah so all right cool this is easy i'm
just gonna take my pill walk out of the
yard i'm good to go
so the guy comes in with the bag and
then he has a security guy with them and
there's two other guys outside standing
guard
and um
he walks up to the first guy he's like
ten dollars
so i'm like oh [ __ ] ten bucks right so
i'm like nah i got my gun when i'm good
right whatever
so me not thinking because obviously now
i'm like
all pumped up and i'm like this is like
my first time ever doing anything like
this and i just came to this unit i'm
like this is so cool
and uh it gets to me and i go to
reaching the ground my money and not
knowing my radio was in that pocket and
when i lift up my shirt they saw my
radio and they're like oh [ __ ] and i'm
like oh my god so the fight just broke
out yeah and you know but me and the guy
are fighting pills go flying everywhere
and now all the drugs actually run into
the yard trying to get the pills and i'm
getting trampled yeah and i'm like
trying to turn my radio on and call for
help
the guy's bodyguard are trying to get in
the yard to get me yeah you know to get
their guy because i had to guide by like
the angle trying to hold him
like i'm like trying to get my guns i
don't know if they got guns and it was
just mayhem man like finally i got up
and i called for help and you know they
took off running and you know it was
like i was like holy [ __ ] like yeah that
was wow man it's like it was just so
chaotic yeah you know but like at that
moment i knew that's what i wanted to do
like just being in that line of work
yeah that rust that i felt like even
knowing i could have been killed right
there like trampled to death or shot or
whatever
that you don't it's like an out-of-body
experience you're looking down on the
situation yeah like man i just went
through that yeah
i've never felt that anything else in my
life like
you know it's like a drug and like i
never been
like i get how people can be addicted to
things because
you that feeling is addictive yeah you
know what i mean like i've been saying
i've been walking away from this job for
the last year and a half yeah and it's
so addictive it's so hard to do because
of how much i love it
you know and yeah it's tough